bang-bang what's up guys welcome to
lunch money episode number 6 or 7
something like that
well while she's trying to get rich
thrust of us just trying to get a lunch
money right I've got the beautiful miss
Polina Mayer Nova the star of the show
here with me you guys can't tell what
she has on jeans and a jean jacket
meaning she's wearing a Canadian tuxedo
today let's get after it
alright what's the first topic some semi
good news maybe the White House advisor
dr. Anthony cheese I hate even said that
Corona deaths will continue to climb in
the US this week but they're getting
close to the peak and the rate of
hospitalization hospitalizations is
slowing [ __ ]
what completely [ __ ] why none of
these people know what they're talking
about here's why but the date is wrong
that's my point is they're all making
analysis on data that's inaccurate we
haven't tested enough people to know
what the actual of death rate is and we
don't know how many people actually have
coronavirus or done so you can't do
accurate analysis okay this is all
guessing but fewer people are going to
the hospital allegedly because hey
here's here's what I would say right is
now what they're doing is before what
they when they didn't have testing what
they were saying was Oh 10 people came
in with the have flu symptoms we don't
have enough tests so just we think you
have coded 19 we're gonna put you in
isolation
yeah because they'd have a test so they
had an abundance of caution so again I
actually believe that it is gonna get
better but my point of like if they say
hey there's a 2% drop is it 2 percent
because actually 2 percent less people
with Kobe 19 are coming in or now that
we have more accurate testing the data
is just getting calibrated we don't
actually know I love with a conspiracy
theorist so it's like a spear severe is
just math it's ok look but good news
though is I do believe that it is
getting better like there there is well
one of the important data points is the
number of people that get coronavirus
and then are now get
because now there's been enough time
after the 14 day quarantine right now
there's people who are being released
and those numbers are actually looking
pretty good and also we're seeing in
other countries who had it much earlier
than we did like they're starting to get
the more accurate data that we all
probably have in three four five six
weeks and a lot of those death rates are
coming down right the mortality rate or
morbidity rate and so when that happens
there's a difference between mortality
and morbidity I believe but I don't
actually know the difference we'll
figure it out
so those data points actually look good
as well my guess is that the United
States is a couple of weeks behind
that's nothing will eventually get that
data as well and be more accurate okay
good so are we are we encouraged do we
feel like bang-bang-bang New York City's
film Oh Joe highlight Joe's got the
highlight going okay other news Jack
Dorsey the CEO of Twitter and squared
says he plans to donate 1 billion
dollars which is under just under a
third of his total 28% right yeah yeah
he's a baller that's a baller and he's
donating it to relief programs related
to the virus and it's really cool how
he's doing it cuz it's like super
transparent he has a Google Doc you can
see item on item by item what he's
donated to and so far I think he donated
a hundred K - oh God whoa okay so a
couple things let's back up say Jack
Dorsey is the CEO of Twitter and also of
square pretty cool anybody who's ever
started and run two multi-billion dollar
companies he's one of very very few
who've done that this is this is this is
not the first time he's done
philanthropic activity a lot of people
forget this but in 2015 or 2016 he took
four hundred million dollars worth of
his Twitter shares and he gave it back
to Twitter employees people of people
forgetting that he did this he took
hundreds of millions of dollars of his
Twitter shares and he gave it back to
employees so like he has this propensity
for helping and doing these with equity
etc he's not taking a billion dollars
right now in like cash I think I think
people should know right when somebody's
do is he's taking a billion dollars of
equity from square which is the 28% of
net worth and he's putting it into an
entity that over time will sell it off
in order to fund this correct
correct in the past he's been criticized
for doing philanthropic you have to
speak up remember that people can't hear
you got talk louder kind of stop
interrupting me so Phil he's he's done
this stuff before but he's been
criticized for kind of doing it a little
bit um not very transparently so now
he's putting it in a Google Doc you can
all see it can we talk about how cool it
is that a billionaire is giving away a
billion dollars using a Google
spreadsheet yeah like that's [ __ ]
awesome why because the one just the
level of transparencies awesome to the
fact that like it's something that's
available that's a free tool like he
didn't go and get like an accountant and
a you know an auditor might do all the
things and like hey I'll release like my
financial report at the end of the year
it cetera he's like now look it's gonna
be super easy I'm gonna eliminate goal
of a Google spreadsheet I'm gonna post
the information there you can click on
this link whenever you want you don't
know exactly what I've done yeah
and so the 100k that he donated is
America's food fund and it has a
GoFundMe and you can literally look at
the link you can donate to it yourself
it's really cool so he only did a
hundred thousand dollars so far man he's
got a long way to go he's got a billion
dollars to give away and he did 100k how
many hundred K so they're gonna be
there's a lot right so I've raised 13
million dollars out of their 15 minute
million dollars well because he also
tweeted about whatever when he did it
and then everyone said hey whatever Jack
does I'll do he's just the man yeah he's
no I mean like if he donated 100k how
come they've only researching okay no
they raised 13 million oh my god we're
only two comma Club over here sometimes
we got to do extra math for those of you
at home bring your calculators to lunch
money because somebody over here doesn't
have the greatest math skills you've
never seen two commas before okay let's
move on to staples
what's going on with staples other
people by the way other people who can't
do maths
speaking of people who can't do math
staples go ahead wait what do you mean
they can't go ahead staples recently
informed its landlords that it will not
pay April rent for its Us stores even
though the locations remain open so
are they allowed to do that well back up
again context to the story staples is
owned by a private equity firm I think
called Sycamore right Sycamore Partners
these people are socialists straight-up
socialists and I can say that because
last year they took a billion dollars 1
billion dollar dividend out of the
company so the way a dividend like this
works is think of it as a billion
dollars is sitting there in the bank
account and the owners just say we're
gonna take that and they dividend it to
themselves they put it in their pockets
rumor well Walsh is trying to get rich
they took the billion dollars and they
put it in their pocket they leave the
company there with the customers all the
assets what's in the bank account
there's a billion dollars less and now
fast forward to order we in April now
all of a sudden now they're telling
their landlords we're not going to pay
April rent and we may not pay Mays rent
but if they had the billion dollars that
the private equity firm took from last
year they'd be able to pay the rent so
whose fault staples staples staples is
the company the owners today right so
what ends up happening here is the
private equity firms what while she's
trying to get rich everyone else is just
trying to get to lunch money so all
those landlords that own that property
they now get stiff because of the greed
and I would argue to kleptocrats see oh
that's not that's not you say it but
whatever you guys know what I'm saying
but because of what those private equity
guys did now all of a sudden the
landlord's don't get their money and if
the landlord's don't get their money for
rent right then what ends up happening
is the banks have a mortgage rights they
only the bank money and you get this
chain effect all because of the greed of
this private equity firm best part I'm
willing to bet they're looking for
government relief or assistance um
unclear I watch this is the socialist
playbook
this is socialism what happens is I take
for me and then I go to the government
and I asked them to bail me out when if
instead I just done the right thing the
money would be there to pay but nobody
expected this would happen that's fine
but you still have the money where the
billion dollars go did the partners put
in their pocket it buy a nice house well
here here's the way I would argue it
right and this this gets into the really
nitty-gritty
was happening the finance world right
now if Staples can't afford to pay their
landlords and they default that company
should go into bankruptcy the government
should not bail them out why should the
government go in and bail out a company
that the owners took a billion dollars
out and is unwilling to put the money
back in the company because the company
thinks the government's dumb they
literally are looking for the dumbest
person room they go and they say I can't
find any other investors to give me
money so let me go get the government to
give me the money because the government
will give me better terms than anyone
else Oh get me stay alert out there stay
alert they ain't here to help you trust
me all right let's move on oh speaking
of a true socialist even better Bernie
Sanders has dropped out of the
presidential race meaning that it's
Trump versus Joe Biden what do you think
of Bernie not like his political views
but just like did you watch the Joe
Rogan like to our thing with them I did
not but I hear that you are like well
okay well amazed is a strong word
basically so on I pretty much I think
everyone knew Bernie Sanders was not
going to be the nomination just the deck
stacked against them and that means that
Joe Biden is now going to the Democratic
nominee to run against Trump which
basically means Trump just won I think
most people recognize that with that
said though Bernie Sanders is definitely
portrayed in the media as very kind of
crazy out there very extreme political
views etc very often seen as a socialist
etc but he went on Joe Rogan and they
did a two-hour interview I think it was
and the beauty of the Joe Rogan kind of
podcast is that in that two hours Joe
just asked simple questions like how do
you think the United States can fund
paying for everyone's health care and
Bernie didn't have to answer in like a
five second kind of like a salacious
clip for the the news or on a debate
stage he could actually explain his
thought process and what I was impressed
by was his ideas were very well thought
out and he came off way less crazy than
he's normally
in the media that doesn't doesn't mean I
agree with a lot of what he says but he
just came off much more reasonable and
much more a higher ability to articulate
his ideas but I was pretty impressed
with that maybe not anymore
but let me can I ask a dumb question of
course I ask dumb questions all the time
what happens when or if sorry what
happens if a week before the election
Donald Trump goes hey I don't want to
run for president anymore does just Joe
Biden automatically becomes the
president early do the Republicans have
to find somebody well so the again I'm
not a election expert but basically if
one candidate says I'm not gonna run
anymore at the last second in bhau's how
long then there's still an election
that's held and in that in that election
you would get Joe Biden verse
technically any other person over the
age of 35 who's born in the United
States Klien could be the president
who's the right people in right now of
course nobody believes a write-in
candidate is gonna win the presidency
but in the case that the Republican
nominee decided not to run which I don't
think has ever happened was there
actually the nomination while it would
be while but I think what when it
quickly happen is somebody would step in
and say well I'll take the Republican
nomination
I'll run etc I mean I don't understand
why somebody would go that far and then
bail out at the last it's not a chance
well that's one thing and also probably
more realistically is like a health
issue right I mean most of the people
who are in politics I think Joe Biden's
like 77 Donald Trump 74 years old
like forget coronavirus type health
stuff just traditional your mid 70 year
old person right like like of course
health complications etc and so yeah
there could be a situation where
somebody bails for health reasons but I
just don't foresee them being like I
woke up today had you know some
breakfast and decided I'm good
I'm going home I just wish our
presidents were maybe a little bit
younger why do you think that younger
people would bring fresher ideas I do
and I think they're a little bit more
innovative and
kind of stuck in the past like for
example did you read that profile on the
prime minister of Finland is a 34 year
old woman I believe and she is the
second youngest leader in the world and
why not yeah of course
a tulsi gabbard she's 38 I think right
what's that
Andrew yang I think he's like early 40s
I think Pete Buddha check or whatever
his name I think he is very young right
and then obviously on the Republicans
had there's plenty of people who could
potentially do that at one day but don't
forget guys the ROC he's coming 2024 is
our year I'm telling you when the ROC
runs for president
everyone's gonna be tweeting I mean I
can't calm it just saying Dwane Mark
Cuban could one day yeah but but again
here's the thing right is like Mark
Cuban has done exactly what you would
need to do in order to did you guys hear
that plan is phone just after she
complained about my notifications now
folks but what could happen is it's all
it's all popularity contests now it's
all about who's got the most charisma
who's getting it has but there's always
been an element of what you almost
needed the the political blood right
like you thought you needed the lineage
you needed to be blessed by like the old
guard obviously Donald Trump blew that
up and so what it does is it opens the I
think the gate now for okay could a
Dwayne Johnson The Rock right could Mark
Cuban could some of these other people
start to step in with no political
experience like we just had one
president right maybe he went senator
maybe doesn't but now that opens up the
the ability for people to do that I
think people will go to do that over
time
well guys the day that they lift the
requirement of needing to be born here
and not be a naturalized citizen or be
an ultra licenses to run for president
I'm there it's pretty tough it's like
isn't it pretty dumb that you have to be
born United say especially because like
if you're not morally United States you
have to go through such lengths to like
prove that you're loyal to this country
you know its history and you take this
test and then you like have these little
flags that you leave and then they're
like sorry you can't run for president
even though you're smart
and Polina president Polina would be the
scariest thing in the world could you
imagine I would dress people with hello
you cats okay all right moving on to the
last topic McDonald's all the Mickey D's
McDonald's has been hit really hard
because of our impact eyes because
they're so global right so like France
Italy Spain like all completely
how much did same store sales fell 22%
of March yes three point four percent
the first quarter 22% in March
look McDonald's is the best restaurant
in the world fact you know why means yes
I know he walks around this like this
and I'm like you literally look like
Arthur at new alright so McDonald's
here's the big thing is every single
restaurant I think is probably going
through this everyone from Starbucks etc
hopefully what is happening though is
that it's geographically controlled
meaning that in end of January beginning
of February like they had to shut down
all of their operations in China right
and then as the virus kind of spread
through the world now all of a sudden
those operations are coming back on but
I think Starbucks it start to open some
of the restaurants in China etc I'm
wondering if McDonald's is gonna be able
to do the same thing
long story short those I don't think
that anyone's not gonna go eat
McDonald's after this I don't think that
anything is wrong with McDonald's and I
also don't think that the virus is gonna
last long enough for it to have a
material impact but there probably will
be a couple of months of loss of revenue
we're sitting at home we haven't eaten
McDonald's so this is what I thought was
interesting the CEO of McDonald's is
cutting his salary in half until at
least September 30th and then you
realize that his base salary was 1.25
million excluding performance bonuses
and four of McDonald's top executives
have also volunteered to reduce their
salaries by 25 percent we do you think
of this and do you think that it's gonna
be like irresponsible for CEOs to take a
pay cut when they're laying all these
people often well it would your I think
your the question trying to ask is would
it be irresponsible for the CEOs not to
take
what did I say no no problem so here's
the here's the two things I think one is
if you take a 50% pay cut from 1.25
million dollars it's really not that
material so the operations of McDonald's
it's like a drop in the bucket it's more
the symbolism of hey I'm gonna take a
pay cut right rather than just lay off
boys employees - though is if you think
about what you want it's kind of like a
doctor when you go to the doctor what do
you want you don't want to go to the
99-cent doctor you want you want to go
to the hundred dollar an hour doctor
who's super expensive because they're
the best in the world one time you took
me to like a 99-cent doctor I think
those exist okay but same thing with the
CEO like the way I think about it is if
you have a big multinational corporation
I'm not one of these people who rails
against compensation because you
actually want the person who says it's
not worth my time unless I get paid an
outrageous amount because I'm worth that
but I'm the best in the world so
therefore you should pay me X right and
so the same thing happens here but the
difference is in peacetime or wartime in
peacetime you don't necessarily need the
best in the world right you just need a
pretty good like if you're running
McDonald's as long as you're not a
complete idiot you should be able to
continue to grow sales and like do
things right I'm sure there's no there's
I'm sure there's idiots that mess it up
whatever but for the most part like it's
a machine there's a lot of checks and
balances in place you've got a good
executive team and all that kind of
stuff right one person it's really hard
like completely messed things up at the
port direction etc in wartime it's the
exact opposite
you need leadership you need the best
leadership you can find and therefore
what you actually want is when you go
into the wartime with the financial
crisis you you should be able to pay top
dollar and be willing to pay top dollar
to get the absolute best person but he's
already there and leader and he wants to
like you said it's symbolic he wants to
show like hey I'm willing to take a big
cut I know who we're all suffering like
I'm not gonna pay myself an insane
amount of money even though he so stands
to get these performance bonuses look
there's like a honor among warriors
right to some degree and if you think of
it from that standpoint what's the most
honorable thing that like a warrior
could do in this scenario it would be to
say hey I'll give up a hundred percent
of my cash
right so I'm not going to get you the
cash I'm instead gonna take all of my
compensation for the next two years in
stock and I won't solve for five yams
yeah and it would just be like damn well
it's like a it's a I'm planning a flag
in the ground I believe in this company
I believe we're gonna weather this storm
I believe we're gonna come out of this
stronger than not and I'm gonna put my
financial skin in the game in doing that
and so if you structure it that way that
would be incredible but at the same time
I look a lot of people look at and
they're like oh my god that guy gets
paid 1.25 million dollars there's a lot
of executives in corporate America
that's two commas but there's a lot of
executives in corporate America that
actually have a lifestyle that matches
their salary so it's not like this guy
used to get paid you know fifty thousand
a hundred thousand two fifty five
hundred million million to five and
never changed his lifestyle instead
would actually most likely happen not to
pick on this guy but just in general is
they bought a bigger house they bought a
car they bought this they got more debt
etc so what I'm saying is they
financially can't give up a hundred
percent of their salary because they
have expenses because they lived above
their means below or whatever and so
ends up happening is it's just a very
complex situation where nobody expected
this to happen and now people are having
to make hard decisions I do think that
this is gonna be a real like a lot of
people gonna realize like hey maybe we
shouldn't live above our means given
that anything can happen at any moment
an entire generation has learned about a
strong balance sheet right now how
important that is strong balance is that
your platform could I've last two
seconds in the Oval Office I literally
would be like they'd be like uh sir you
can't say could a president win without
wearing a tie every day like like they
do on the campaign trail sometimes now
became cool like Obama made a photo and
roll your sleeves up all that kind of
stuff but like could it president
actually do it without like a without a
button-down or like a business shirt ah
like Zuck who ran for president I don't
I don't think it's possible really no
you don't look professional yeah it's
not professional enough
well Pollyanna
for president I would wear all sorts of
suits you have a Canadian tuxedo let's
be serious all right that's awesome what
else anything else any closing words for
the people the people are my friends
don't tell them about the comments how
you appreciate all their comment I love
the roots do I ever change clothes yeah
Dawg listen I got a bunch of black
t-shirts I got a hack so I haven't
gotten a haircut
if possibly about time we get at a
quarantine I may even cut my hair into a
mullet but I wear the same black t-shirt
and I'll let you guys in on a secret
don't tell anyone I have a pair of
sweatpants shorts that I've been wearing
every single day of quarantine I'm now
going on
what are we 1718 days yes I got sweaty
shorts on right now I'm coming to you
live from the kitchen polina hates it
all right guys appreciate it that's
lunch money for today do you have
anything else no because your friends
vote for me if I ever run beak on to
your friends alright that's guys that's
lunch money for today while wall she's
trying to get rich the rest of us just
trying to get a lunch money right and we
will be coming to you noon ish ish
because we don't have our [ __ ] together
before noon afternoon right at noon or
at 5:00 p.m. today we're actually
recording this at like 1:15 so we're
really behind but I appreciate you guys
watching every day as long as Polina
continues to be on her best behavior she
will be a co-host if at some point she
disrupts us has notifications go off
again breaks the dress code or just
generally annoys the [ __ ] out of all of
us we will replace her so thanks so much
I'll do with an imaginary person all
right guys we'll see you tomorrow